yeah so that's one thing i'd recommend
is the books books about the
from the original people especially
heisenberg about the
how that happened and there's also a
very very good kind of history of
of the kind of what happened during this
20th century
in physics and you know up to the time
of the standard model in 1973 it's
called the um the second creation by um
pop crease and uh and man that's one of
the best ones i know that's but the one
thing that i can say is that so that
book i think
forget when it was late 80s 90s
the problem is that there just hasn't
been much that's actually worked out
since then so
most of the books that are kind of
trying to tell you about all the
glorious things that have happened since
1973 are
they're mostly telling you about how
glorious things are which actually don't
really work and it's really
the argument people sometimes make in
terms in favor of these books as well oh
you know they're really great because
you want to do something that will get
kids excited and then you know so
they're getting excited about things
something that's not really quite
working it's doesn't really matter the
main thing is get them excited
the other argument is
you know wait a minute if you're getting
people excited about ideas that are
wrong you're really kind of you're
actually kind of discrediting the whole
scientific enterprise in a not really
good way so there's
these problems so my uh
general feeling about expository stuff
is yeah it's to the extent you can do it
kind of honestly and and and well that's
great there are a lot of people doing
that now but
to the extent that you're
just trying to get people
excited and enthusiastic by kind of
telling them stuff which isn't really
true this is you really shouldn't be
doing that
you obviously have a much better
intuition about physics i i tend to um
in the space of ai for example you could
you could use certain kinds of language
like calling things um intelligent
that could rub people the wrong way but
i i never had a problem with that kind
of thing you know saying that a program
can learn its way without any human
supervision as alpha zero does to play
chess
to me that um
may not be intelligence but is sure that
as heck seems like
a few steps down the path towards
intelligence yeah and so like i think
that's a very peculiar
uh property of systems that can be
engineered so even if the idea is fuzzy
even if you're not really sure what
intelligence is
or um
like if you don't have a deep
fundamental understanding or even a
model what intelligence is if you build
a system that sure as heck is impressive
and uh showing some of the signs
of what previously thought impossible
for a non-intelligent
system then that's impressive and that's
inspiring and that's okay to celebrate
in physics
because you're not engineering anything
you're just now swimming in the space
directly when you do theoretical physics
that it could be more dangerous you
could be out too far away from shore
yeah well the problem
i think if physics is it in a i think
it's actually hard for people even to
believe or really understand
how
that this particular kind of physicist
has gotten itself into a really unusual
and strange and historically unusual
state which is not really i mean i
spent half my life among mathematicians
and applicant physicists and you know
mathematics is kind of doing fine people
are making progress and it has all the
usual problems but also
so you could have a
but but you just i just i don't know
i've never seen anything at all
happening in mathematics like what's
happened in the specific area in physics
it's just
the kind of sociology of this the way
this field
works
banging up against this harder problem
without
anything from experiment to help it it's
really
it's led to some really kind of
problematic things and those so it's one
thing to kind of
you know oversimplify or to slightly
misrepresent to try to explain things in
a way that's not quite right but it's
another thing to start promoting to
people
as a successes ideas which which really
completely failed and um so i mean i'm
i've kind of a very very specific
if you so have people
won't name any names for instance coming
out certain podcasts like you're telling
the world you know this is a huge
success and this is really wonderful and
it's just not true
and and this is this this is really
problematic and it carries a serious
danger of um you know once
when people realize that this is what's
going on you know they
you know the the loss of credibility of
of science is is a real real problem for
our society and and you don't want
you don't want people to have an all too
good reason to
to think that what they're being
what they're being told by kind of some
of the best uh
institutions in our country or
authorities is is not true you know it
is
it's not true it's a problem
that's it's obviously a characteristic
of not just physics it's uh
it's sociology yeah
and it's uh i mean obviously in the
space of politics it's the history of
politics is uh
you um
you you sell ideas to people
even when you don't have any proof that
those ideas actually work you speak as
if they've have worked and that that
seems to be the case uh throughout
history
and just like you said it's human beings
running up against a really hard problem
i'm not sure if this is like a
particular
uh like trajectory
through the progress of physics that
we're dealing with knowledge is just a
natural progress of science you run up
against a really difficult
stage of a field
and
i
different people that behave differently
in the face of that
some sell books and sort of uh tell
narratives that are beautiful and so on
they're not necessarily grounded in um
solutions that have proven themselves
others kind of uh put their head down
quietly keep doing the work others sort
of pivot to different fields and that's
kind of like
yeah ants scattering and then you have
fields like machine learning which is
there's a few folks mostly scattered
away from machine learning in the in the
90s in the winter of ai ai winter as
they call it but a few people kept their
head down and now they're called the
fathers of deep learning yeah
and and they didn't think of it that way
um
and in fact if there's another yeah i
went to they'll just probably keep
working on it anyway sort of like uh
loyal ants
to a particular
sure yeah
so it's it's it's interesting but you're
sort of saying that um
we should be careful over hyping things
that have not proven themselves because
people will
lose
trust
in the scientific process yeah but
unfortunately there's been other
ways in which people have lost trust in
the scientific process that ultimately
has to do actually with all the same
kind of behavior as you're highlighting
which is
not being honest and transparent about
the flaws
of mistakes of the past yeah i mean
that's always a problem but um this
particular field is kind of fun
it's a
it's always a strange one i mean i think
in the sense that
there's a lot of public fascination with
it that it seems to speak to kind of our
deepest questions about you know what is
this physical reality where do we come
from and what and these kind of deep
issues so there's no there's this
unusual fascination with it mathematics
this verse is very different nobody
nobody's that interested in mathematics
nobody really kind of expects to learn
really great
deep things about the world from
mathematics that much they don't ask
mathematicians that so
so so it's a very unusual it it draws
this kind of unusual amount of attention
and it really is historically in a
really unusual state it's kind of it's
gotten itself
way kind of down uh
down a blind alley in in in a way which
it it's hard to find other historical
parallels but sort of push back a little
bit there's power to inspiring people
and if i just empirically look
physicists
are really good
at
um combining
science and philosophy
and communicating it like there's
something about physics often that
forces you to build a strong intuition
about the way reality works
right and that allows you to think
through
sort of and communicate about all kinds
of questions like if you see physicists
it's always fascinating to take on
problems that have nothing to do with
their particular discipline they think
interest in interesting ways and they're
able to communicate their thinking
interesting ways and so in some sense
they have a responsibility not just to
do science but to inspire
and not responsibility but the
opportunity and thereby i would say
a little bit of a responsibility
yeah yeah and sometimes but um i don't
know anyway it it's hard to say because
because different um there's many many
people doing this kind of thing with
different degrees of
of success and
whatever i i guess one thing um
but but i mean my what's kind of front
and center for me is kind of a more
parochial interest it's just kind of
what
what damage do you do to the subject
itself
ignoring
misrepresenting you know what high
school students think about string
theory and not that doesn't matter much
but but what the smartest
undergraduates or the smartest graduate
students in the world think about it and
what paths you're leading them down and
what story you're telling them and what
textbooks you're making them read and
what they're hearing and um and so a lot
of what's motivated me is more to try to
speak to
as kind of a specific population of
people to make sure that look you know
people
it doesn't matter so much what the
rest of what the average person on the
street thinks about string theory but
you know what
what what what the best students at
columbia or harvard or princeton or
whatever who are who really want to
change work in this field and want to
work that way what what they know about
it what they think about it and that
they not be go into the field being
misled and believing that a certain
story this is where this is all going
this is what i got to do
um is it is way that's important to me
well in general for graduate students
for uh people who seek to be experts in
the field diversity of ideas is really
powerful and is getting into this local
pocket of
ideas that people hold on to for several
decades is not good no matter what the
idea i would say no matter if the idea
is right or wrong
because there's no such thing as right
in the long term like it's right for now
until somebody builds on
something much bigger on top of it it
might end up being right but being a
a tiny subset of a much bigger thing
so there you always should question sort
of the uh the ways of the past
yeah yeah so so how to kind of achieve
that kind of
diversity of thought and how to within
kind of the sociology of how we organize
scientific research is i know this is
one thing that i think it's very
interesting that uh sabine hassenfelder
is very
interesting things to say about it and i
think also at least mullen in his book
which is also about that i mean they're
very
very much in agreement with them that
there's
anyway there's a really kind of
important
questions about you know how
how research in this field is organized
and how people
you know
what can you do to kind of get and get
more diversity of thought and get more
and get people thinking about um
about a wider range of ideas
at the bottom i think humility always
helps
well
but the problem is that it's also it's a
combination of humility to know when
when you're wrong and also
but also you have to have a you have to
have a certain very serious lack of
humility to believe that you're going to
make progress on some of these problems
you